في الحرب الاوكرانيه شن الجيش الاوكراني
هجوما صاروخيا على مدينه ميليتو بول ذات
الموقع الاستراتيجي في جنوب شرقي البلاد
ما اسفر عن مقتل شخصين واصابه 10 اخرين
وفقا ما اعلنته السلطات المواليه لروسيا
هذا واكد حاكم الذي عينتهم موسكو للجزء
الذي تسيطر عليه روسيا في مدينه
الدفاع الجوي دمرت صاروخين فيما وصلت
اربعه الى اهدافها واضاف ان مركزا ترفيهيا
كان ناسيه تناولون فيه الطعام دمر خلال
الهجوم الاوكراني بصواريخ مارس الامريكيه
الهجوم الاكراني ادى ايضا الى اصابتي
كنيسه حولها الروس الى مكان للتجمع في
المقابل غرقت مدينه اوديساسه ساحليه في
جنوب اوكرانيا بظلام بعد اطلاق روسيا
طائرات مسيره لقصف منشئتين للطاقه ما ادى
الى انقطاع الكهرباء عن واحد فصل خمسه
مليون شخص